all right zoom announced they're going
to acquire five nine for 14.7
billion it's zoom's largest acquisition
to date zoom is sitting at about 105
billion dollars
and this is an all stock acquisition
represents about 15
of the company so this is a whatsapp
like that remember when facebook
spent all that money on whatsapp or it
might be similar salesforce buying slack
it's a big bet
zoom's first acquisition over a billion
dollars if you don't know five nine
um it's uh it helps companies run
contact centers remotely and provides
tools that automate tasks distribute
work and report on effectiveness
zoom founder eric wan noted uh they made
this investment because i'm gonna
paraphrase here
five nine provides a really simple
platform if you're a customer support
agent you can work from home
and you can do all that remote obviously
zoom helps people work remote so this
is you know kind of adjacent to them
this should accelerate zoom's phone
system they have a
cloud phone system uh and our the ceo
rowan trollope actually was on this week
in startups episode 917 in april 19.
uh so congratulations to ro and friend
of mine um and uh we'd love to have
rowan back on the pod i think he's going
to come on after
all this and hopefully uh we'll have
eric on at some point
okay keith reboy's open dot store just
went live as we were taping
this show uh pretty brilliant idea i
asked keith if i could invest and the
round was closed hopefully he can sneak
me into a future round i think it's a
brilliant idea
but basically this is being set up
open.soar
to acquire a bunch of e-commerce
companies there has been
a massive boom in people starting
shopify stores
or becoming third-party sellers on
amazon
so the brilliant idea that keith has
here is
what if you bought all of these and put
them together under one roof
and uh entrepreneurs just fill out a
form uh they link their shopify accounts
and open store will give them an offer
for their business within one
business day so the key there is
that they link their shopify accounts so
they can see the quality of the revenue
make an offer
and the transaction according to open
store will close in days not months
without a broker
uh so this is like an m a roll-up play
iac
did something like this you know buying
all of the
different assets they have barry diller
we had uh on our program actually josh
silberstein he was on episode 1094 back
in august of 2020 in the middle of the
pandemic
and he is pursuing something similar uh
they were the fastest unicorn ever
created from founding to unicorn
according to
most people's take on it and um they
just bought a bunch of businesses that
were third-party sellers and then
you let them operate independently but
you maybe get some uh scale because you
take the marketing practices or you have
cross-marketing or common accounting
common
growth techniques maybe you have some
databases of users so you get some lift
there
if you have one if you have two brands
uh you know maybe you can't create a
database of
you know more than a million people but
if you have 200 brands maybe you can get
a database of 100 million customers
and then understand them cross-sell and
advertise to them so with scale comes
all of those economies of scale so
congratulations to them
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together
let me guess way too much well odoo is
here to help
odoo is a suite of business apps that
runs your entire company
on one platform they'll streamline your
workflow
to bring all that information together
plus odoo's integrations eliminate
repetitive tasks and data entry
if you only need two or three apps to
optimize your workflow
that's all you're going to pay for odoo
won't stick you with the bill for apps
you don't use
and odoo has an app for every business
need they offer 30 main apps
that are updated regularly and over 16
000 apps
from their active open source community
you can keep your books tight
with their financial software you can
add their sales and crm apps to help
provide a clear and organized view
of how you're doing as a team and here's
your simple
call to action your first app is free
forever and right now odoo is offering
a thousand dollar credit on your first
implementation pack
that's not a joke one thousand dollars
off go to odoo.com
twist to check it out odo.com
twist